all right I represented Thomas they
might call it a candor about his actions
last time almost stopping or certainly
delaying the last stimulus package
didn't win him any support of the White
House the president said he was
grandstanding that maybe he should be
primary others on both sides of the
aisle had even the answer things just
say but he said he's sticking to his
guns now that this is just more spending
on top of more spending talking about
250 billion dollars in addition to the
small business loan the commitment that
is really cooll the paycheck but a
protection program Lindsey Graham
Georgia right now in South Carolina what
he makes of what Nancy is trying to do
something good to have you what do you
think he's saying enough already cool it
who Massey yeah we were talking about
was that your question what I think of
him yes saying mm-hmm
is that your question yeah well I
wouldn't well he doesn't want any more
money being spent he says enough he says
enough well yeah yeah I get it he never
wants to give a dime to Israel so we can
spend a lot of time talking about him
but I'd rather not let me tell you why I
think this is a good program the small
business loan but it's got a major
problem back here at home I've heard a
lot of criticism and concern about the
program the goal is to keep the
employer-employee relationship intact so
what do you do you go to a bank if you
can find one you borrow up to two and a
half times your payroll as of what what
existed February the 15th you pay your
employees 75% the money has to go to pay
the payroll and that keeps the company
intact so when the economy opens up
you're good to go count me in for that
but here's what's not working the banks
are hard to access here in South
Carolina you have to have a pre-existing
relationship so there's not enough banks
is too bureaucratic but we can fix that
the big problem with this program is the
unemployment program is competing with a
loan program here's what happens if you
own a restaurant in South Carolina you
pay employees $17 an hour well here's
here's your dilemma you're paying them
$17 an hour to stay on your payroll
the South of South Carolina's
unemployment system spend them $23 to
leave your payroll so we got very
generous unemployment benefits that
exceed people's wages and it's hard for
the small business to keep their
employees on the payroll because the
state of South Carolina is offering them
$23 not to be on your payroll if we
don't fix that we're never gonna get
this right you know I wonder on when you
quote stimulus at generous measures for
those out of work if you caught a today
senator that Governor Cuomo New York
wants to add to the unemployment checks
that people are getting in New York buy
another $600 on top of the $600 that
they're getting through the federal
government so he says that the federal
government will reimburse him but what
do you think of that here's what I think
I believe that this is an
entrepreneurial nation and if people
like to work but they're gonna make the
decision best for their family
my goal is if you get laid off and you
can't go to work no fault of your own
and nobody will offer you a job that we
make you hold that if you were making
$15 an hour that's $600 a week I want
you to be made whole the maximum
unemployment benefit per week in South
Carolina is 326 dollars I'm willing to
make up the difference but what we've
done is we've added $600 on top of 326
so now you're making $23 an hour
so the problem is if you're Walmart and
Amazon Neal you know this better than I
do and you're trying to plus up your
workforce the state of South Carolina to
Texas is $28 an hour we've made it hard
for people to find new workers because
you're paying people more not to work
I'm for making people whole but I'm not
pre paying them more not to work than
they were making at their job all right
well I have you senator on there's a big
kerfuffle between the world health
organization of the president the
president is concerned about what the
w-h-o knew and when it knew it and I'm
wondering whether as he has talked about
maybe taking funding away from them
because they were hiding figures on
China that's the allegation and the
severity of the growth of the virus in
China what are your thoughts on this
well the Congress appropriates money
we've got money in the pipeline for the
WHI we need an effective W
Joe but I'm not going to fund the w-h-o
any longer as long as the current
director is in place he must resign I'm
going to be dr. know when it comes to
funding the WH o it is the account then
I'm in charge of I just signed a letter
today with sixty members of Congress
Republican and Democrats complaining
about the WH o they said on January the
tenth is okay to travel to China when
they should have known better on January
the 14th they said there was no evidence
of human transmission of the virus
within China they should have known
better
in 2015 they completely botched the
Ebola virus problem in West Africa so
the current regime is not a good
investment no more money for the whu-oh
until they get new leadership and reform
the way they do business all right
senator we'll see what they say what
they do because they're fighting fire
with fire we'll have an update on that a
little bit later Senate Lindsey Graham
thank you very very much